خصف في مستشفى الشفاء ضرب النازحين عدد من
الشهداء القذيفه سقطت هون ايش اللي صار
ايش اللي صار ايش اللي صار الله اكبر الله
اكبر قصف قصف في مستشفى الشف افتح
طريق قصف ماوى النازحين في مستشفى
الشفاء اس ايش اللي صار
يا عم
قول ه الضربه لا
اله تعرفهم
يابا تعرفهم يابا قوات الاحتلال تقصف ماوى
النازحين داخل مستشفى الشفاء تقصف
النازحين داخل مستشفى الشفاء يلا
فقصه النازحين داخل مستشفى
الشفاء عشرات الشهداء في هذا المكان عدد
من الشهداء في هذا
المكان
يلا
[موسيقى]
من حسب
الله انتشال الاصابات
والشهداء حبل الله ونعم
الوبل الله ونعم الوكيل
[موسيقى]
رو يا شباب يلا يا
شباب وسع وسع
افتح طبعا لا يوجد كب تعامل مع كل هذه
الاصابات التي وقعت في داخل مركز الاواء
الذي يحتوي على الاف النازحين عشرات الاف
النازحين داخل هذا المجمع من يقوم الان
بعلاج هؤلاء الاصابات او هذه الاصابات هم
نفسهم السكان